hey perfecto
bienvenido de regreso ahora vamos a
empezar una nueva sección vamos a
trabajar con la sección 6 la cual
empieza en la página 407 de la guía de
estudio oficial del s arte así que
empecemos los problemas vamos a empezar
el problema número uno ahora bien
recuerda que estos problemas tienen
algún truco detrás lo que nos hace
problemas que se resuelven de una manera
rápida y muchas veces estos son
realmente sencillos lo que los hace
rápidos de resolver así que si tú
empiezas a resolver un problema y
empiezas a tardar te en la solución unos
4 ó 5 minutos tal vez no sea la forma
óptima de resolverlos tal vez la
estrategia que usaste para resolverlo no
sea la mejor tal vez correcta pero no
óptima así que la primera ecuación que
tengo aquí me dice lo siguiente x + 2 /
x esto tiene que ser igual a 5 + 2 entre
5 y justo a este problema lo estaba
analizando antes de empezar el vídeo y
es un problema muy sencillo pero además
es un problema que ejemplifica perfecto
lo que quiero decirte este problema
tiene dos formas de atacar la solución
la primera es usando una fórmula
cuadrática pero esto parece que nos va a
resultar un poco tardado y la segunda es
un plan ultra rápido y más porque
tenemos incisos te voy a poner aquí los
incisos de este problema me dice que el
inciso am es un quinto el inciso b me
dice que es cuatro quintos el inciso se
me dice que es 1 el inciso abc de el
inciso de me dice que es 5 medios
y por último el insisto en me dice que
es 5
ahora quiero que te des cuenta que hay
dos formas de resolver este problema la
primera sería dándonos cuenta que aquí
tenemos una ecuación en la cual está
involucrada xy entonces podemos pensar
vamos a resolver para x y para resolver
para x aquí tendría que hacer la
operación de estos dos quebrados me
quedaría 5 x 5 25 + 227 quintos y
después podría multiplicar todo por x de
tal manera que me quedara x cuadrada más
2 esto es igual a 27 quintos de x y
después resolver la ecuación cuadrática
esa sería la forma larga de resolver
este problema porque también hay una
forma más fácil de resolver este
problema fíjate bien cómo voy a leer la
ecuación x + 2 / x esto tiene que ser
igual a 5 + 2 / 5 no te suena a que hay
algo familiar por aquí además recuerda
que estamos hablando del primer problema
de esta sección debe de estar muy
sencillo por lo tanto date cuenta de lo
siguiente aquí tenemos una
y a esto le sumamos 2 entre esa misma
equis y por otra parte del otro lado
tenemos 5 + 2 entre ese mismo 5 y además
estamos de suerte porque se repite este
2 este 2 y este 2 es el mismo entonces
si yo tengo x + 2 entre x igual a 5 + 2
en 35 como que ya suena que tenemos la
respuesta no es así claro que te parece
si vamos a resolver esta ecuación
sustituyendo a x por el valor de 5 si x
vale 5 entonces que voy a obtener 5 + 2
entre 5 esto es igual a 5 + 2 entre 5 lo
cual es completamente cierto por lo
tanto la forma fácil de resolver este
problema es viendo que en nuestras
opciones tenemos el 5 nuestra respuesta
correcta es el inciso y además es
también padre porque yo en un principio
cuando vi este ejercicio me dije changos
aquí tengo involucrado una ecuación
cuadrada y después me tarde con unos
tres segundos más en decir tal vez
exista otra forma de resolverlo me fije
las opciones y me di cuenta que era un
problema de patrones lo único que había
que hacer es darse cuenta que cuando
sustituimos a x por 5 llegamos a la
respuesta correcta así que bueno
bastante sencillo pase de tren problema
déjame borrar el pizarrón y vamos a
hacer nuestro segundo problema problema
número 2 muy bien y en esta ocasión nos
dan un triángulo rectángulo por cierto
así que está de lujo esto tengo mi
triángulo por aquí así que aquí está mi
triángulo es un triángulo rectángulo y
por cierto me dicen que este lado vale 2
esta es mi hipotenusa es un triángulo
rectángulo tenemos un ángulo recto la
hipotenusa se llama james y este otro
cateto vale x que por cierto me dicen
que x vale 3 me dicen que en este caso
en este problema x vale 3 y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale james y si te
das cuenta es simple y sencillamente
cuestión de aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras el teorema de pitágoras que
que me dice que la hipotenusa elevada al
cuadrado es igual a un cateto elevado al
cuadrado más el otro cateto elevado al
cuadrado así que la hipotenusa en este
caso james me va a quedar que ye
cuadrada
es igual a un cateto al primer cateto
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 2 x 2 que
es 4 lo mejor de que me ponen 2 y 2 al
cuadrado más el otro cateto elevado al
cuadrado pero el otro cateto es x que
por cierto vale 3 entonces más 3 elevado
al cuadrado y de aquí tengo que cuadrada
es igual a 2 elevado al cuadrado lo cual
es 4 + 3 elevado al cuadrado lo cual es
94 más 9 es trece entonces de cuadrada
es igual a 13 y por cierto si lo que me
piden es bien hay que sacar raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados de tal manera
que me va a quedar que ya es la raíz
cuadrada positiva de 3 y ya está que por
cierto es el inciso a así de fácil y así
de sencillo estaba este problema así que
de una vez vamos a hacer aquí el
problema 3 déjame cambiar de color y
vamos a poner aquí el problema 3 que
dice si un número es divisible entre 2
es divisible entre 6 entonces es
divisible entre 4
bueno vamos a ver qué más dice cuál de
los siguientes valores que tenemos en
nuestras opciones contradice este
enunciado así que déjame ponerte aquí el
enunciado si un número es divisible
y
visible entre 2
y entre 6
entonces es divisible entre 4 entonces
es divisible entre 4
y me dan aquí cinco opciones y lo que me
preguntan es cuál de estas cinco
opciones contradice el teorema así que
vamos a ponerlos el inciso am es 4 el
inciso b es 8 el inciso c es 12 el
inciso d es 18 y el inciso m es 24 así
que vamos a ver el primer insisto es el
inciso a am y es 4 pero a date cuenta
que cuatro no funciona aquí porque no es
divisible entre 6 es divisible entre 2
pero no es divisible en 36 por lo tanto
no me sirve ahorita el 4 el 8 el 8 es
divisible entre 2 pero no es divisible
entre 6 por lo tanto este tampoco me
sirve para que este enunciado se
contradiga el 12 el 12 es divisible
entre 212 entre 2 y 6 el 12 es divisible
entre 62 en 36 es 2 el 12 también es
difícil de entre 4 2 entre 4 estrés esto
quiere decir que éste y no contradice el
teorema vamos a ver si hay otro que si
contradiga el teorema el inciso de dice
de
1818 es divisible entre 2 18 entre 2 es
9 18 es divisible entre 6 18 en 36
estrés pero qué creés 18 no es divisible
entre 4 así que esta es mi respuesta
correcta este no sirve y esta es mi
respuesta correcta porque encontramos un
número que sea divisible entre 2 que sea
divisible entre 6 pero que no sea
divisible entre 4 y el 24 por cierto es
divisible entre 2 entre 6 y entre 4 por
lo tanto tampoco me sirve bueno estos
problemas están muy fáciles así que
vamos a hacer un último problema por
esta ocasión dice problema número 4 y
tiene una figura así que vamos a hacer
esta figura dice en la figura que está a
continuación que es una figura más o
menos
tenemos un rectángulo y después tenemos
por aquí
un círculo déjame ver si me sale el
círculo es parecido a este círculo
muy bien y además me dicen que estas
distancias 12 y que esta otra distancia
es ahora
y además me dan cuatro puntos este es el
punto b este es el punto am este es el
punto cm y este es el punto d y con todo
esto además me dicen que el lado b c y
el lado abdel son tangentes al círculo y
recuerda que tangente es que tocan al
círculo en solamente un punto y lo que
me preguntan es cuál es el área de este
círculo cuál es el área de este círculo
y por cierto recuerda que el área de un
círculo se saca multiplicando a pi por
el radio elevado al cuadrado ahora si te
das cuenta lo que necesitamos es el
radio y el radio es la distancia que hay
desde el centro de este círculo que voy
a decir que es más o menos por aquí
hasta alguno de sus puntos es decir no
puedo tomar hasta este punto de aquí y
bueno si te das cuenta como este círculo
toca a estos dos lados entonces yo sé
que la distancia que hay desde aquí
hasta acá es 8 porque es el dato que me
dan es decir que esta distancia es 4 y
esta otra distancia esta de aquí también
va a ser 4 el diámetro vale 8 y por lo
tanto cada uno de los radios vale 4 y ya
tenemos el valor del radio así que el
área va a ser igual a pin que multiplica
al radio elevado al cuadrado es decir a
4 elevado al cuadrado y entonces me
queda que el área es igual a 16 mm lo
cual es el inciso a así que aquí está mi
respuesta el área de este círculo es 16
mm y bueno como el otro problema tiene
que ver con gráficas y ya no tengo mucho
tiempo lo voy a dejar para el siguiente
vídeo así que nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo